so the trouble to chinese property
company evergrant has avoided defaulting
on an overdue payment by just a whisker
evergrand wired 83.5 million dollars on
friday to a citigroup account for a
missed bond payment that had been due
september the 23rd that's according to
the securities times evergren's struggle
to reduce its more than 300 billion
dollars of debt has prompted fears of
default might triggering a financial
crisis the news lifted evergrand shares
in hong kong
uh clearly that's something to discuss
for one with clifford coonan who is in
the studio here with me hi clifford and
christy plattson who joins us on the
frankfurter stock exchange christie and
i would actually like to start with you
because we had this talk yesterday about
share price plummeting a different
picture today how did the surprise
payment go down on international
financial markets
well monica investors were certainly
happy to hear this news out of china at
least when it comes to european stocks
we saw them climbing on the news there's
still a lot of debate about what a
collapse of this company would mean
whether it would take the chinese
economy down with it and have major
spillover into international markets so
by making this initial payment that
shows that things still seem to be under
control for now
so between this and also some strong
corporate earnings performances that
we've seen this week investors seem to
be in quite a good mood today here in
europe you know there's a lot for
markets to worry about right now along
with evergrand we're also still dealing
with supply chain issues fears of
inflation and let's not forget that
we're still in the middle of a pandemic
as well
but all that being said uh european
stocks are near a six-week high today
and that certainly has something to do
with this news out of china today
yeah surprising news and good news
apparently how good uh that is something
i would like to know from uh clifford
could it be that we've underestimated
evergrand's will to survive
well i think um i think what this will
do is it'll buy everground some time but
it's like sticking plaster on a gaping
wound it's it's really a very very small
amount of money um i think it has a will
to survive and uh xujayin the
chief executive the founder and chief
executive of of everground is is a
survivor he's been in this he's not okay
it hasn't been as bad as this but he's
been here before and he's managed to
pull things around i can't see him
pulling things around though i think
this is um there's clearly something
else going on here it's a much bigger
problem it's it's kind of a systemic
problem which ever grant is just like a
symbol of or an indication of in a way
of a much deeper malaise in the economy
so um i think it definitely has a will
to survive and it's bought itself a
little bit of time but i don't think it
signifies anything that's going to be
going to any massive change in in the
direction it's headed okay so you still
believe that eventually uh the direction
is
it will collapse sooner or later
but what does all of this and the latest
development in particular now tell us
about the state of the real estate
market in china well i think it shows us
that china has a debt problem
and this is going to affect all of us
eventually obviously it's going to be a
domestic issue
and that the real estate the real estate
sector is in a mess so um basically with
the combination of all these things
they're all connected um it's a little
bit like christie was saying about you
know all the different factors that work
in the market at the moment you've got a
similar thing happening in china you've
got a lot of things going on um
and uh you know industry house prices
are falling uh industrial production is
is uh prices are rising production is
falling there's a lot of different
things for the government to contend
with and there's one other factor that's
very important which is that there's a
key political meeting coming up next
month at which xi jinping the chinese
leader will want to cement his position
and possibly lay the groundwork to have
another five years in power which is
unprecedented so that's a very important
political issue which means that the
government is going to try everything to
make sure that nothing happens to the
economy in the next in in the medium
term anyway so there's a lot of these
different factors going on at the moment
and i think none of this is going to
help um given the fact that the real
estate sector really is in a terrible
state they certainly have their work cut
out for them there uh clifford [ __ ] and
as always thank you so much and of
course uh christy platson in frankfurt
thank you to you as well and from my
side already uh have a nice weekend
you